ED GLAESER: If you live in a city, then you trade in that city.
You buy, perhaps breakfast or a newspaper or something more exciting.
You sell as well, probably your time to an employer.
You may well have come to your city precisely because you could sell
your time at a higher price.
In this section, we are going to explore how cities make markets, and
how makes make cities.
And hopefully, you will come to understand your city a little bit better.
Cities typically have a wider range of services.
Scale makes that possible.
Meaning that there are more types of restaurants, more rare goods, and
more specialized services like nail salons or bespoke tailors or fortune tellers.
Internet retailing has leveled the playing field between city and town for
many products, but not for services that require face to face contact.
Not for restaurants, and not for
higher end products that you want to see before you buy, like diamonds.
Cities enable labor markets to work more efficiently.
You can hop from job to job more easily in a big metropolitan area.
You can weather a mass lay off more readily in a city.
And that helps explain why joblessness is lower in metropolitan America.
If you run a business,
you will find it easier to find the labor you need in a large metropolitan area.
The success of cities often depends on how they do as markets.
When labor markets break down, as they did in Detroit after the faltering
of the Big Three automakers, the city itself spiraled into decline.
The collapse of retail on main streets in the US and
high streets in the UK has often left a great emptiness in the heart of the city.
Internet-based markets like Uber and Lyft enter into urban areas and
they take advantage of urban scale.
Yet they also upset regulators
who often try to protect incumbent businesses from competition.
Understanding the interplay between cities and
trade is helpful if you want to understand how to get the most out of your city or
if you wanna make a guess about what's its future will be.
Or if you just want to sensibly discuss policies that impact trade,
like the regulation of Uber or food trucks.
Hopefully, these videos will help you to better understand the past and
future of commercial cities.